so let me start by introducing the cast
of characters they're all very simple um
before we get to a little bit of history
and results
so we're going to be discussing
we'll be comparing comparing metric
spaces this is completely standard
whenever you have a metric space and a
binock space
will denote by c sub x of the metric
space is the smallest
uh capital d such that you can find the
mapping
which preserves distances up to a factor
capital of d so this is the notation and
i'll also write it like this
as
m embeds with distortion capital d into
x
now another very simple object that will
appear here
is the discrete heisenberg group
which is a
very very simple uh to understand
it's generated by two elements a and b
and it's i'm going to give it to you in
terms of generators and relations a and
b and there's only one relation actually
two relations which is that the
commutator of a and b
is in the center
so if
from now on the rest of the talk c is
going to be the commutator of a and b
and the conditions are it has to compute
with the generators so this is two words
of length nine or something
so this is the heisenberg
and um
but if you want to be concrete
then um
and it's worthwhile we will see it later
you can also realize it as the upper
triangular matrices which ones in the
diagonal with regular matrix
multiplication and integer entries
and the correspondence is that this is a
and this is b and then the commutator is
c and indeed c computes with everything
so you can check and these are the same
groups so but for you can get
a lot of what i i'm gonna show you don't
even have to think about matrices you
can think of just in terms of generators
and relations
so but it's good because i want us to
think of the heisenberg group often is
r3 or z3 and this is the identification
x coordinate y coordinate and z
coordinate so the vertical coordinate is
the corner up there
this is the coordinate going up
and so the word metric on the heisenberg
group corresponding to this generating
set it will never matter what generating
set we're looking at is denoted by d sub
w the word metric
and this is again a very simple object
so we can draw the kd graph this is i'm
using the correspondence x y z
so these elements of the groups are
indexed by integers and here is the
kelly graph
so you connect
an integer point to
x to x times a or x times a inverse or x
times b or x times b inverse so the
blues are the a's i think
and the reds are the inverse and this is
just very concrete graph degree 4 graph
on the integer lattice and then dw is
nothing more than the shortest path
metric on this graph
okay so this is the metric space that i
care about in this talk
and again a little bit of notation
b sub n will always be the um
the ball of radius n in this discrete
group
and there are these are
facts that you can easily prove by
induction
so remember c was the commutator so if
you raise c to the power k
then it's then you moved from away from
the from
um
the unit element the identity element by
root k so this is like the
characteristic property of the heisman
group i can go vertically remember c was
the vertical direction i can i can
when i move vertical distance k
in the group i actually move the only
distance root k
actually though there's a path of length
order root k going up distance k
c part of the vertically generator
from now on c is the commutator of the
generators no it was not part of that
the generator set for the kelly graph
was just a and b but this is irrelevant
everything is up to constants change the
generating set to any other generating
so throw it in if you want it will just
change the constants
well all all telegraphs on finite
generating sets are equivalent to each
other up to constants so this is just
irrelevant choose your favorite one but
no i didn't include
um
so
so this is root k and the number of
elements in the bottom right is m is up
to two constants m to the four okay and
with my the generating said i wrote you
direct actually closed formulas for all
of these things you can
everything is a completely well
understood
um but we just care about up to
constants
okay so um the the the third and final
actor in in the
storyline
is the notion of uniform convexity which
is again very simple
um your if you have a norm space there
it has a modulus called the modulus of
uniform convexity which is given by this
formula but the picture is very simple
it says
take two elements in the unit let's say
this is the unit ball take two elements
on the boundary of the unit ball so
they're unit vectors
suppose their distance epsilon
look at their midpoint the midpoint is
inside the ball this is just the fact
that this is a convex set
uniform convexity means that
it's not just inside the ball it's
inside the ball by at least delta and
delta is independent of the pair of
points
okay so this is what uniform convexity
means
and um
so this is the notion that x is
uniformly convex if delta is positive
for every epsilon
it said it's q convex if this delta is
at least epsilon to the power q so
q convex means that when you have two
points of distance epsilon
and the boundary
then their midpoint is inside by at
least a constant times epsilon to the
power q in hilbert space for example
it's epsilon squared this is the
pythagoras theorem
and um
and um this is a notion of q convexity
so well i said cubonoxine means there is
an equivalent norm so you're allowed to
change the unit ball by um a constant
factor and then get this a convexity
property
and a deep important
beautiful theorem of pieza from 1975
says that
if you're uniformly convex then you're
actually q convex for some q so the fact
that there exists some delta
as a function of epsilon any function
immediately means
that by changing the ball by a constant
factor you uh you can get the delta to
be a power
okay this is a
wonderful result very useful result
um of pc from 7d5
so just to be concrete i already said
that hilbert space
is too convex this is the epsilon
squared and for lp if p is less than two
um you are too convex and and for p more
than two your p context
and i think this is all of the
introduction that i had to tell these
are the three
these are this is the only
the only background that you need to
understand the talk
and the beginning of the story is the
following very famous theorem
uh
well
sam's in 1996 noticed that
um work of pencil which itself was a
clarification and improvement of
important work of musta
so in 1996 sam's noticed that this work
i'll explain
says that the metric space this very
simple kelly graph on r3
shortest path metric doesn't embed into
rn for any n
there's nothing at metabolism bending
into any n
into our n for any n
okay so the shortest path metric on this
graph on r3 doesn't fit into our 100 or
a million in a very definite way at all
now
this is a famous result it's a it's
solved that it's famous because it
solved the time of famous open question
a central open question and i want even
though it's not directly related to what
we're doing i want to tell you why this
is famous
okay so um the background is a swad's
embedding theorem
which is an extremely
it's related to an extremely natural
steel open problem in in metric spaces
in metric geometry
and it says the so it starts with so if
you give me an integer k
we say that the metric space is k
doubling if any ball in the metric space
can be covered by that if k is 100 let's
say 100 balls of half the radius so the
picture is
choose a radius through the center here
is the ball
and then you can cover it
here in this case i think by 14 balls of
half the radius and this is to happen
at all locations and at all scales so if
you know the ball is somewhere here and
it's smaller than the same picture holds
and you can imagine a three-dimensional
picture this is a finite dimensionality
property
of a metric space
now what is a good example of a finite
dimensional metric space that's rn with
any norm for example
um
so
in what a smartel tells us in 1983 a
very important theorem is that
there is it's this doubling condition
almost characterizes it's a near miss it
almost characterizes by lipid symbol
ability in rn
so if you give me a metric space which
is k doubling
then if you raise an exit on a tiny
number so the power is going to be very
very close to 1 here
raise the metric to the power 1 minus
epsilon
this object is already in summer n
with distortion and depending on the
parameters of the problem
the doubling constant and the epsilon
and the dimension in the epsilon as an
aside i should say that i found this is
quite surprising that you can actually
get the dimension to be independent of
epsilon so with epsilon goes to zero
your matrix is becoming closer and
closer to the original metric space that
they mentioned let's say if it's
five doubling it's going to always be a
hundred
okay
so and and i should just advertise that
this was a probabilistic proof there is
a simpler clever deterministic proof of
gidavid and mary snipes which is recent
which gets worse bounds but if you just
want this phenomenon that you can embed
into r100 that's it for let's say five
doubling matrix places
then it's simpler to read
so this is the story
i'm rewriting aswad's theorem and
there's
i'm sorry
so
well
playing in the sense that we don't know
the correct dependence either here or
here but we can get the same
dependencies i just don't think it's
tight no it just mentioned that epsilon
affects the oh yeah this remains
dependent on epsilon
but this is the point i want to get to
okay but here is the obvious question
that you raised completely obvious
everybody who saw the swath's theorem
ask themselves
why do we need to raise the metric to a
power one minus epsilon
okay why what maybe it's true that any
doubling metric space embeds into our
end by lipschitz sleep not first take
the metric and raise to the power one
minus epsilon well raising to a power
one minus epsilon is very close to the
original metric but it's very violent
for example it doesn't have any curves
of finite length anymore
you don't need to raise the metric to a
power less than one in your previous
thing this is known
could it be log k basically
yeah everything is known and this is
really a digression i can tell you
there are there are lots of things
so there are many big open questions
here but
but there are good bounds which are
we don't know sharp results and actually
knowing sharp results in these problems
is very important but not for the topic
of this talk
um
so where were we okay so this is the
obvious question and and of course this
is what sam did in 1996
13 or 15 years after a swat
so
because i just told you a moment ago
that the number of elements in a ball of
radius m is up to a constant m to the
four this means that this number group
is a doubling metric space
because if you have m to the power four
elements in a ball of radius m the mean
of all the radius m over two there is m
over f also proportional to over four so
if you take
a net you will cover by you it's really
boundedly many balls that cover it
and so it's doubling and we just said
that it doesn't have been in any rn for
anyone
okay so that's why this is a big deal
it's still a big deal and then um
it's such a big deal that uh okay so let
me just say a few words about
just buzzwords of
how this is proved
um
because this is a general philosophy of
all the proofs except for one which is
going to be the topic of this talk
so the general philosophy is
you prove
that um
you want to rule out my literature
visibility you prove that
if there exists a biolipids mapping then
there's also very nice well structured
by liquids mapping a nicer one in some
sense
and then maybe with algebraic properties
and then use algebra to
to finish the proof to rule this out so
there is some sort of a limiting
argument that pencil proved approved the
nonlinear version of rather macho
theorem almost every differentiability
except that now these are groups so
there's a non-commutative version of
this it's unimportant but here is a
statement that you get in the end
so if the heisenberg group embeds by
lipschitz into rn then it also embeds
but now the biolithics mapping happens
to be a group homomorphism
the minute somebody tells you that it's
finished because forget about the fact
that it's by ellipse it cannot be
injected you cannot a non-commutative
group cannot be isomorphic to a subgroup
of the additive group of our n which is
a billion
okay so at this point forget even the
fact that it's by electric it's
injective game over and this is a
general philosophy called metric
differentiation
which we do a lot in metric embedding
theory we always
look for arguments saying that
if there is some sort of embedding then
there must be a much better one for
which we can use more structure and here
it was a billion verses not a billion
so
these papers are all the papers that i
found that reproved a
this sends theorem
um it's not fair to say they reproved
each one of them added more so each of
them each of one of them added new
information new classes of metrics such
as which heisenberg doesn't embed et
cetera et cetera but this is generating
a lot of interest for many reasons i
will show other reasons later
and i will men and but
and all of these results belong to this
general philosophy of
using some sort of limiting argument to
say
there is a better structured mapping
uh and then we can rule it out rule it
out using maybe algebra or some other
structures
so i will say a few words about some of
them i should just say that these two um
papers essentially what exactly showed
that the original argument of pension
um just carries over um when the target
space is uniformly convex there's even a
more general class of spaces so it's
this heisenberg group this very simple
cable graph and r3 it's not only true
that it doesn't embed into our n it
doesn't embed into any infinite
dimensional uniformly convex black space
and there are many many so paul's proved
that he doesn't emit into certain other
geometries with curvature bounds etc etc
so each of these papers add more to the
story
i want to say a few words of this paper
with a
a team and romantic sarah
um so this is addressing the
quantitative question
which
when you see this a
limiting argument you see that it
actually is an issue so this is a very
soft
argument which doesn't give bounds
and using a completely different proof
we can prove the following so if you try
to embed the ball of radius n with this
word metric inherited from the scaly
graph
into hilbert's space infinite
dimensional hilbert space in particular
order rk
then the the distortion of this is up to
universal constants root login
okay and
and i'll say a few buzzwords so again
you it's the same sort of philosophy
so you you're some sort of limiting
argument and again and some sort of um
averaging argument um which shows
something more which shows that if there
were a billion bending into hilbert
space
then there would also be a values
embedding which is an additional
structure it's what's called the one
call cycle associated to an a to an
action of the heisenberg group and
hilbert's space by fine isometries i i
won't we don't need to know those who
don't know what this means this is a we
know we won't get into this at all it's
not relevant to the talk but this is
more structured this algebraic structure
there's an even all the result of this
which shows that the
the embedding can even have more
structure called core boundaries and
then when you have so much structure
you're having a fine action on hilbert
space of the heisenberg group and a very
nice embedding
then you can analyze it using the just
the irreducible the representation
theory of the heisenberg group is known
and you can just analyze it using
representation theory and get this a
root login
so this is a very hill version argument
but it's still the same philosophy it
goes via us showing that there is that
if there is anybody puts mapping then
there is also a better one
and then we can use algebra
now for q convex spaces or uniformly
convex race is it um
the proof from the paper uh gave the
following bound so if you have a bonus
space which is q convex
then the ball of radius n requires this
much destruct distortion
uh
when embedded into a
acute contact space how
um
so let me just tell you so where does
this this is again using some sort of
algebra so the qualitative statement is
the following first of all so
you could it's not only true that it
doesn't embed by lipidsly into a
um
into a uniformly convex space it doesn't
embed by lipschitz lee
into what's called an ergotic amount of
space provided the embedding is again
this this
coming from a group action a one call
cycle
um a badass is ergotic if the ergotic
theorem is true on it so if whenever you
have a norm one operator an isometry
even from x to itself and you have a
point you look at the ergodic averages
they converge in norm
okay so we can relate
uh
the embeddability properties of the
heisenberg group to the ergodic theorem
l1
okay but the
so reflexive spaces this goes back
probably to foreign actually in the 30s
reflection spaces are neurotic
and um i'll tell you i'll clarify this a
little bit more okay but um
um so where were we okay so um
so it doesn't embed into so there is
some link to the oregonic theorem
and how do you finish
the proof so this was provided the
embedding had this algebraic property
it's related to some action of the group
and paris and i proved that for the case
of q convex spaces it suffices to rule
out
embeddings which have this algebraic
property
but this uses an ultrapower argument
and um and that's where you use lose the
ergodicity so
for this everybody a ultra power
argument to work um
uniform convexity is needed so this is
maybe answering spaces whose ultra
powers are ergodic is the same as
uniformly contact spaces this is a
beautiful theorem of brunel and such as
then from about overpowers from the
1970s so we understand all of these
things
and um
so we
we get this additional algebraic
structure
in the presence of uniform convexity and
then the game uses the algebraic proof
that use it used the fact that it has
this additional structure
but you need to prove rates of
convergence in the mean ergodic theorem
that's a subtle point because there are
no rates of convergence
in the naive senses so you have to come
up with a certain notion of what does it
mean that the ergotic theorem converges
quickly
and you can do it
so again these are just buzzwords we're
going to i'm going to show you proofs of
these which don't use this structure in
a second
i this final result that was in the list
of results is due to sean lee um
he managed to go to pansu's
differentiation proof and make it
quantitative but it doesn't give the
the correct powers of log but still you
can do that
okay so this is just background now i'm
answering your question i'm going to
tell you
that these things are almost sharp so
this is what a swat proved in these
papers if you have a metric space which
is k doubling with constant k otherwise
the parameters here will depend on that
constant
then um there is some number k
and a sequence of one leap sheets
mappings from the metric space into rk
with the property that if you give me
two points in the metric space and their
distance happens to be between two to
the j minus one and two to the j
then it's my lipids and those pairs
it lip sheets they're all one big treat
so you have the upper bound
then it's my lipsticks so this is what a
squad proof
and then of course
just concatenate them right so
how many
the distances in the ball radius n are
between zero and two okay one and two
and the non-zero distances so the number
of powers of two that is relevant is log
and if we concatenate them then now
every pair has one coordinate which is
fine
but i paid in the liquids constant how
much did i paint the liquids constant in
lp
so in each coordinate if i write the
liquids condition i get
one lipids but there are log n
coordinates so the liquid content is
logged into the one over p
so this is this shows you that up to
these log log terms
um
this is sharp
and this gives this completely
with a mortal version proof
okay
okay so
so here is the
the new result which is
really the topic of this talk
this is a a work that i did with one son
laforg
and
uh we're gonna
you're gonna see we're gonna get sharp
results without even log logs for all of
these problems
but the main point is the proof rather
than the bounds
uh i really believe that it
seems at least that in order to get
sharp bounds we need to depart from this
metric differentiation approach this
approach of trying to find
a more structured embedding
and this is just a direct proofing for
the analysis
okay a little with paley theory and we
proved the following fact just an
inequality
so you have a banner space which is q
complex so this geometric property that
two points on the boundary of the ball
their midpoint are inside by at least
epsilon squared if their distance is
epsilon epsilon q to the power q
if their distance is epsilon
take absolutely any function from z
cubed into x this is just
and you have the following thing so
let's look at this so what's written
this is upon korean equality so what's
written here oh let's start here you run
over all the ball all the points in the
ball of radius n
and for such a point you move it
vertically remember c was the the
commutator the vertical direction
well in coordinates you moved it
vertically k but this is distance root k
in the heisenberg group
okay and you look how much displacement
how much your function varied along so
you take any point in this
ball radius and enough vertically above
at a point of distance root k
so x is uniformly distributed there is a
correct normalization you sum over all
the possible k's
and this is always bounded by
so this is why this is called this is
the vertical global displacement so this
is vertical displacements of vectors but
the distances are jumping are big they
can go up to n squared
and i'm comparing this by an actual
gradient
okay so this is what's called the
horizontal term
here the remember a and b were the
generators
so the distance between x a and x is
just x and x form an edge in the scaly
graph that they drew
so looking how much a f changed along
the kd graph
and of course this is the other type of
edge the two generators
and
and you see that well this 21 is not
important this is just an artifact of
the proof there is a constant
independent of n such that if you sum
the gradient on a ball which is blown up
by this constant that will always bound
the vertical displacement
so the horizontal displacement controls
the vertical displacement
and this is for vector valued
a function so this takes in space with
this happens in functions taking
taking values in a space with this
uniform convex geometry q uniformly
convex
so i'll say a few words about the proof
in a second
there is actually what's writing here is
there's some
what's
interesting about this inequality is
that there is actual
cancellation interesting cancellation
happening here this is
uh
what's hiding behind this is a
phenomenon in free analysis where you
actually find cancellations between
things okay but is
in one second i will get to it okay um
but let's first see how it finishes so i
here this is what i said so unlike the
previous proofs these 11 or something
papers that existed
this is just going by hand you're not
taking a function and you're saying
on some small scale it looks almost like
a homomorphism or it looks nice or
anything like that you just take a
general function and just prove an
inequality for it so it's direct
it's based on
semi group methods and littlewood
palestine inequality actually a recent
version of the littlewood palestine
inequality martinez torrential this is a
deep fact
that they proved in 206
and there is a geometric argument that
we hope to get to some of it later
but this is direct
um
and i should just say if you care only
about embeddings into lp then you don't
need these more sophisticated
inequalities you can open a textbook in
harmonic analysis and take the classical
little paint inequality and that will
work in the proof just as is
okay
so let's first deduce from this the
sharp noun invisibility
so suppose
you have a
a mapping the mapping has a probability
that i understand the ball of radius 22
and some doesn't matter um it's my
lipsticks with distortion d so it
doesn't contract distances and it's
expands by most factor capital d let's
suppose this happens this was the
gradient the horizontal gradient term in
the inequality
so each of these terms at most d times
this is a distance in the between x and
x is an edge in the kelly graph so this
is a one
and this is a one as well so but
everything is raised to the power q so
we have a d to the q right here
number of terms is the number of
elements in this ball
which is of order end with a four so
this is the upper bound
let's examine the
the vertical displacement
so now i'm going to use the lower bound
so this is at least the same thing
but with distances in the heisenberg
group in the graph
and i said that the distance so this is
this is a left invariant matrix which is
the same as the distance from c to the k
to the identity element this behaves
like root k
so it's to the power q is k to the q
over 2. i normalize by k to the q over
2.
so i have a harmonic sum sum k goes from
1 to n squared doesn't matter
times the number of elements in the ball
of radius n but i got this additional
login term
so when you compare these guys
that's i'm just copying the inequality
that we proved which is the main theorem
it says that this is
uh this is a
this is what has to hold the end to the
fourth cancel then you see that the d
must be big
up to a constant so the in our notation
the distortion of the ball of radius n
with the word metric in in this q
uniformly conducts bonus space is at
least log n to the one over q
and this is exactly matching what i gave
before for this what the swad already
proved for the embedding of the ball
so
in particular for lp you can do many
other spaces here's the truth
so if you look at this scale graph
shortest path magic on the in the graph
look at the ball of radius n ask how far
is it from
uh
from embedding from a subset of lp if p
is less than two it's root log n if p is
more than two it's login to the one over
p and this is
the correct asymptotics in it
okay so we only know this before when p
was two in hilbert space but that was a
very hilarious proof it used
representation theory
and and and i have no idea how to
generalize that proof to the to any
other setting and this somehow
circumvents all of this
okay so
okay so um i want to say a few words
about the proof but i actually want to
get to
a
conjecture and they're linked to
computer science
and this is is also work in progress
but i but
and this will also answer uh yeah
i told you what it was
i mean i
well there are i i get i get from this
swan theorem but actually i know many
many i can give you close formula
embeddings but
on a piece of paper okay there is
in in the that was what that's what it
was for a general doubling metric space
but
i mean for this particular case you can
even give a formula
okay um
so let's
discuss the sparse cut problem and again
i'm
i am
just an overview
it's a very very simple problem to state
uh algorithmic problem the input
is two symmetric functions so you assign
two functions c and d
c stands for capacities d for demands we
don't need to know this they're just
symmetric functions
assigning a positive and non-negative
number to every pair of integers
the goal is to estimate in polynomial
time this ratio so what's written here
this this is you run over all possible
subsets of the numbers 1 to n
this term here is non-zero only if i is
in the set and j is not in the set or
vice versa so this counts the total c
weight going across the boundary divided
by the total d weight
and the goal is to compute this v star
of cd in polynomial time
so
i know there are many computer
scientists here they saw this before but
there are also mathematicians who
haven't seen this before so this is
extremely simple to explain
this looks like an isoparametric type
problem
this is some of the ratio between
boundaries of two different measures
and you want general measures and the
set of numbers one to one
okay so this is the sparse cut problem
extremely important special cases of
of it
are using subroutines of many other
optimization problems so this is a the
question about partitioning
a general
weighting scheme
on the numbers one to n with general
weights so that you minimize the
interface between the parts and by
choosing your c's and these you can
you can
use this for many problems this is a
very basic problem in computer science
mathematics
so
again i do not need to say but there is
something called the government's linear
semi-definite program which is the
best-known algorithm for sparse scott
um it's some sort of continuous
relaxation you minimize a certain energy
continuous energy
those who know know it's not relevant
for our talk
and it was suggested by gomez and niel
at least in writing i've seen it in 1997
probably much before
um
and the best and this is the state of
the art the state of the art is and this
is the the best known algorithm is that
if you want to compute this number fee
star of cd in polynomial time
i can do it
up to a a factor i can output always
always up to the number which is
guaranteed to be this
up to a factor of root log n up to
little o terms
okay so there's a way to do this without
looking at all the possible
subsets of the numbers one to n actually
a tiny fraction of them polynomially
many of them so
this is similar in for those who come
from continuous mathematics this is
similar to trying to say that
minimal surfaces or isoparametric
minimizers have additional structure you
don't have to look at all the possible
partitions
you have to look at special partitions
okay
so the link to the heisenberg group is
the following theorem
whatever this number is we don't know
what it is so you look at the smallest
by possible by literal distortion of the
ball of radius n
into the band of space now l1 not lp
whatever this number is there will
always be a choice
of
function c and d
which fool the government's linear
algorithm by at least this number a
constant times this number
okay so
i care about this number because i know
that this fools
the government's linear algorithm
okay
now um
so here is the best known bound so there
is some universal constant such that
this distortion is again
um
at least log into this power so this
gomezinian algorithm
must make a mistake of at least some
power of log and some inputs
and um and they come by duality so from
the non-invitability you get the weights
through a duality statement
the fact that this goes to infinity was
previously proved by chigra and kleiner
actually two different proofs
and the quantitative version
so this again belongs to this was one of
the papers in the list that i i listed
this again goes
via the same philosophy so you rule out
a more structured embedding
in a certain sense
and and and this and um what is i'm
using in the quantitative version so the
quantity version there is some sort of
classification theorem happened here
sets with certain properties look in a
certain way
and in the discrete version
the answer to the classification problem
is is genuinely different so there is
there is a classification problem whose
answer is different and doesn't have a
counterpart in the in the qualitative
case so there is a
there's some some something more
happening in the discrete world
genuinely and we have examples that does
not exist in the continuous case but
this is the best known bond
and um and here is
my conjecture i believe that it's a
and i will explain to you
a little bit of why i believe that it's
finished so
we do not know how well this is one of
the most basic algorithm problems a very
very simple algorithm that everybody
studied
look at this algorithm we have no idea
how it performs excellent i believe that
the answer is root log n
and um
and okay and more speculative i believe
this is also the limit for this problem
there is a special case of this problem
uh called the uniform sparse scot which
is
a special a special case of series in
this one they're just zeros and ones
and then this is just computing the
expansion of a graph
in this special case
there is evidence
vague evidence at this point but at
least i see a beginning of a reason
why uh
the root so it again the root log n was
known to be best this is a famous
theorem of aurora was irani
for the same algorithm of governments
and nemo but i believe that there is a
chance at least for this special case
you can do better i don't believe you
can do this for the general case but
there this is there is a lot work
remains the best on lower bound
is this one so it's another power of log
but there is something interesting
happening
but we should not do this to well also
to this but
the word before this there was a power
of log log
it's a lower bound and not for sorry for
for a
for the non-uniform sparses cut the the
gomez
must make a mistake of at least the
power of log log
no no no definitely this is what i'm
saying here i'm saying that i do not
believe that for the uniform case
you get the same sort of bond
for the general case
it's a log into some power but i believe
that you do not need to change the
example
you don't need to do anything you just
have to prove a certain geometric fact
that i'm going to show you
there don't there's no issue of
constructing something new or anything
of this type we just need to understand
this example which is independently
interesting and then i'll show you what
i think is the geometry here okay so
i think we know the answer and there is
even and i'll even show you a way to
prove it okay
a strategy a program
but another program a conjecture
um
and um but for the uniform case i think
something better
has a chance so i'm definitely saying
that they're different
okay
this is clear so this is the conjecture
and here is a
what a conjecture is true
so
it's a very simple inequality there is
an intuition behind it which
i hope to get to
and it says the following so you have a
function a very nice function it's
smooth and compactly supported as many
derivatives as you want
from r3 from this room to the real line
and you do again a vertical versus
horizontal gain here so what's going on
here
you look at
the display look at f x y z plus t minus
of x y z so you take a a point a a
uniform point in r3 xyz
and you
move vertically above it distance t
take the l norm l one one
of the
um of a this displacement
this is the thing that they took a while
to find so
and now you square the l1 arm so you
notice the square is outside the
integral the integral is actually to the
power one
integrate this with a current certain
weight dt over t squared is a natural
there's no other option if you
understand the scaling variance of this
problem
and that's bounded by the following um
so it's the l1 norm of the the fdx
and plus the l1 norm of the fdy plus xdf
dzl in a second those of you who know
the heisenberg group immediately
understand why i wrote this i'll explain
where this is coming from
in a second and this by a manipulation
implies what i said
okay now i have a lot of evidence for
this one of them is that i know this for
every p bigger than one so if instead of
putting power p
here a power one here you put power p
and then the correct normalization is 2
over p
then um then this is simply true the
same inequality this is
the same method
and this is already the reason
when you understand why this is true
even for p equals 2 there is interesting
cancellation happening here so this is
already using interesting fourier
analysis this is a
um and and and just the belief is that
the constant
currently our proof gets
something that explodes as pretense one
i believe it does not explode
and there's
all sorts of evidence let me tell you
the geometric interpretation
so here is a
a very simple it's an iso parametric
problem this is the answer to your to
your
question
which i think is a very intriguing iso
parametric problem
so take any nice measurable subset of
this over three of this room
okay
and and the number t
and let and the vertical perimeter at
scale t v t of a is just you look at the
measure the volume the three-dimensional
volume of those points in r3 so that if
you add t
above it you leave the set
okay and um and the conjecture is that
um
that this vertical perimeter
if you integrate so look vt of a squared
over t squared again i'm squaring this
this integral is at most
the square of the horizontal perimeter
the horizontal perimeter is just
a
so if you take let's say smooth
functions that convert to the indicator
of your set
then the the l1 norms of these of these
fields
of this
this inequality incline that no no this
is a theorem
you prove this in quality the game is
over
what is the theorem
the this implies this is the conjecture
the conjunction this is the conjecture
i should have said theorem a positive
answer to the conjecture finishes the
problem
and i'm telling you an equivalent
what is the horizontal and vertical here
so
you can see this is vertical
right i'm looking vertical displacement
this is horizontal in the sense that
i'll draw the picture in a second
in the sense that it's a well i'll see
in a second
um but what's going on here is that
if f was a really nice smooth
approximation of an indicator of a set
then the thing that's supposed to be
bigger will tend to what's called the
horizontal perimeter if the set is nice
and smooth you can give a formula
there's some boundary measure on the
boundary what is the difference between
horizontal and vertical so here it is so
in the discrete world so think of your
approximating r3 by a very fine mesh
okay so the vertical perimeter is going
to be
exactly you you have some subset of the
grid
you look at
what is the
number
of the points in the set
such that if you move
distance t vertically you leave the set
and you sum these these numbers up some
of the squares of these numbers
appropriately weighted
the horizontal perimeter is just going
to be the number of red edges leaving
the set red or blue edges actual edges
of the kelly graph
leaving the set
actual boundary in the graph of the set
and i claim that this vertical is
bounded by the horizontal squared
okay
so
the distinction between vertical and
horizontal is just
okay
this is a language issue this is
obviously everybody agrees this is
vertical we're in this room with okay so
we people call this horizontal because
it's not the vertical
okay
i mean you have to somehow give words to
these things
there is more to this okay but but but
but
in in in our world these blue edges are
horizontal but just what what i mean by
that for now
for for the purpose of this stock is
that it's not
the vertical direction okay but this is
the this is the
edges of the caligraph
okay so i won't have time to show the
proof but let me just show you the link
between the continuous and discrete here
and then i'll end i'm really confused
about what this horizontal thing is
which is this one
can you just explain to us what that is
on the right just again on the right
this guy
on the ground
oh you have this in the grid case it's
take a subset of the grid
and look at how many edges in the
calligraph leave it that's all that's
the perimeter so
this was the iceberg
if you have some substitute or some blob
and you just count how many
blue and red edges leave it so it's
really just that it's that's all that's
all this is in the discrete world and
there's a continuous version of this i
can give you a formula
is that i mean what you call horizontal
is simply the boundary in the caliper
it's the boundary because it's not the
horizontal or anything it's a boundary
in the calligraph and you compare it to
something which is not in the kelly
graph which is actually
generally vertical yeah
this is just a boundary i'm saying it's
an isoparametric problem
it's two different boundaries now the
intuition is this is what's about the
heisenberg you can move vertically
the vertical direction is the commutator
of the of the two generators so you can
go directly vertically using four
multiplication by computating the
generators using horizontal movements
so it should be true
non-quantitatively at least
that if the
boundary in the calligraph is small it's
hard for you to leave the set along the
edges
it should also be hard for you to leave
the set
along vertical jumps because the
vertical gems are built out of
horizontal edges
okay
what's
not obviously
is that um
at this point not knowing is that this
is the correct dependence
this weighted sum of squares
between the vertical horizon this is a
fact about r3 about z cube if you want
there is nothing exotic happening here
okay
so um
do i have 30 seconds who
30 seconds reset i i won't explain the
proof of this explain the link what are
these derivatives coming up from again
analysts who've seen this before already
know so i'm doing it just so you won't
think that there is something mysterious
here with these derivatives
um so this is first of all an equivalent
form
of the discrete
of the um no now i'm actually the main
theorem the one that actually solved the
problem for uniformly convex spaces
so this is an equivalent form from it of
it except this should be the norm
actually not this is the norm in the
band of space
this is the original thing this is just
a continuous version which is completely
equivalent the equivalence
is is a
just a partition of unity argument
okay so this is a that's a computation
this is equivalent to the theorem that
they stated initially
and what are the what is the link so
maybe i should well i
um
the verdict remember there was the sum
of vertical displacements along the
center was bounded by edges of the
caligraph
so here you see the vertical this is
completely obvious
how is this related to the edges let's
just look at infinitesimally what does
movement along these the edges do in the
heisenberg group so take a general point
x y z and move it epsilon in the
direction of the generator a
so multiply matrices this is just adding
epsilon to the x coordinate
and the derivative is just the
derivative of x but if you do it to
the y coordinate you do epsilon in y
this is what happens and then this is
the derivative so that's the reason this
is really the same inequality as a
discrete and you can pass from one to
the other very easily using a partition
of unity argument
okay
so this is the problem and um i just
wanted i hope to show you the proof this
is a semi-group argument and using
little woodpecker theory but that's for
a separate talk i'll stop here
yeah yeah so all of these arguments
never use i only chose the heisenberg
because it's the smallest example and
the proofs for other medium groups are
identical and they don't they're not
illumina the same proof works for
other groups for them to not embed in
the
uniformly contact space you mean that
the center is distorted
so in the heisenberg group it's the
square root thing but there can be other
powers and but it's it generalizes in a
non-interesting way just going through
the motions
is there so there is uh you know this
notion of two boundaries i saw
you explain what it is in a particular
setting these groups and the commentator
and
is it interesting you know
i mean
this is exactly the question uh that
well close to the question that ben
asked which is
the two boundaries the other direction
the vertical direction has to have a
meaning
you know in a group yeah so it should be
vertical but what you are saying is that
the vertical mean direction of the
center you are comparing expansion
using uh one type of generators to
expansion using another type of
terrorism no the other one is not a
generator vertically you cannot
necessarily yeah
so this uh it's the center it's the oh
it's it's yeah yeah yeah so
yeah i'm just wondering if there are
other settings not
groups
so
as as far as i can tell it's ben's
question so it's nilpotent groups of the
natural way place to look at because
exactly you have this the commutators
play a role and there this whole thing
is just the same
works the same and in general if you
want to skip with other groups you have
to mix you have to find the good
direction and that's a good question to
ask
i think this is more a question about
coming up with the right question
uh
in different settings
but
yeah maybe i can tell you something
about the free group but it's not going
to be what's the notion of vertical i'll
have to it's much more subtle yeah so i
do know something about the free group
and also certain solvable groups but but
it changes a little bit there are
inequalities that compare these two two
notions yeah but i think neopotent is a
natural world and in this particular
case heisenberg is there's no reason to
pass to other interpreting groups
well i know everything you want to know
about the free group already so i i i
there is an analog of this conjecture
but there is it's a theorem
so
a little bit more abstracting is it
correct to say that
you get insights from computational
complexity on questions
on metric embeddings which
which then don't use at all so the
computational complexity gives you back
insights on how the metric world behave
no not in this case i'm sorry
in many cases yes not in this case in
this case in the case of this
government's linearity yeah so
so there is there is a big history here
which is
um the gomer xenon conjecture was a
certain a certain um
uh conjecture it had an intuition which
was based on
and the fact that it was known for
commutative groups that's all the work
of the kona castellian craving from the
60s
okay so this fact that if you have a
matrix race with square root is in l1
then it embeds into l1
this was
known in commutative settings
so
when you look at the classical analysis
literature and somebody asked you is it
true in general so what would be your
first guess
okay let's go one step important the
closest possible you can do to
and that's the first place where it
fails
so that's the reason the heisenberg came
out that's initially why we're thinking
about the heisenberg it's like
it's once you know what's going on then
this is the first the next natural state
is
related to computational complexity
inside
so had it been hit head commands
linear conjecture was true this would
have
oh yeah then it would then then it would
mean the decent bends
complexity
uh
is related to computational complexity
yes definitely and we're over there all
the old constructions of the older
construction of of cotton vishnoy came
from computer this is was is really so
what i showed now about the first step
neil potent and the analysis is the
really in many senses the first guest
for a counter example that a geometer or
an analyst would have come up with the
constructions that came from computer
science are really new they were not
something that people tried before and
they came from a complex from
hardness reductions
okay so definitely it led to new
constructions that we haven't seen
before
this is classical this is so you cannot
say that the heisenberg came from from
this direction but uh this is some of
the first guests but there are many
constructions that came from complexity
that's
yeah so
but as i said you can view this as a
negative result but
i think this isoprometric problem would
be a positive result
a nice fact about our three that we
don't know
no no but
it's an isoparametric theorem which is a
and when you actually understand what's
needed for it it looks like something by
the way i'm not sure very difficult but
it looks like a twist on on something in
harmonic analysis is needed um it could
be this is we're close to the end i
don't i'm not so sure this is a very
difficult conjecture
okay but it looks it's it comes close
and there is
uh it looks like something
a new a new nice thing in harmonic
analysis is
needed the vienna 10 25